My name is Brent Dicesare.
I'm one half of WD Detailing.
And today, we're going to be cleaning
an extremely dirty car that used to belong
to a hoarder who's now in treatment.
When we first got this car,
we actually had to leave
it outside of our shop
for over a week just to let it air out,
because it was one of the
worst-smelling vehicles
that we've ever been brought,
only because there was
so much grime and grease
in both the carpets and the seats
and there was just a ton
of garbage everywhere.
When we opened the
doors, I started gagging.
We both had respirators on.
We couldn't do it without it.
The first thing we did
was use the ozone machine.
The ozone machine removes
air pollutants and odors
while also killing bacteria
and viruses inside the car,
which makes it a lot safer
for us to work in there.
After taking the seats out,
the first thing that we do
is take all the trash out
and completely vacuum the car.
That way we can really see
what we're working with.
So, when you see a car in this condition,
it doesn't always make
too much sense to save it,
but this car was brought to us
by a really, really nice
gentleman named Parker.
He reached out to us and told us
that he wanted to clean the car
and give it away to someone
who really needed it.
That really touched us,
so we were instantly in.
As we were vacuuming, we
found a pile of dead bugs
that were just sitting on the carpet
right next to the back seat,
and it was mixed in
with some hair and just
some of the goodies when
you're detailing disaster cars.
When people leave food
or anything of that sort
that starts breaking down,
that's when the maggots start
appearing in their cars.
They vacuum up pretty easily,
as long as they don't
splatter all over the carpet.
But even then, you can just extract them.
This garbage was so stuck on,
we literally could not
get it off with our hands.
Even a power washer isn't
good enough to get it off.
So we'll use a flathead
screwdriver occasionally.
That helps get stuff off of the surface
that we otherwise wouldn't be able to.
It actually wasn't sticky or oily.
It was kind of like a
rough feeling, like Velcro.
It's almost like that rough feeling.
That's how bad this carpet was.
If we didn't pull the
carpet out of this car,
there was no possible way
we were going to get it completely clean,
especially with all the stains on it.
You would normally want
to replace this carpet,
but we were trying to keep the budget
as low as possible, as per Parker.
That's what he wanted to do.
So the original color of this car's
carpets, floor mats, seats was a gray.
And when we got it,
they were almost black.
The stains in the carpet came from ...
I don't even know, honestly.
We were just assuming that it's, like,
grease and dirt and
everything mixed together.
We have this carpet brush
that will get any hairs out of the carpet,
because this carpet also had
what seemed like dog hair in it as well,
and we got all that out
with a vacuum and our brush.
We used a degreaser instead
of an extractor soap,
only because degreaser is a bit stronger.
And then we went ahead
and drill-brushed it in
to start getting it to work into
the fibers of the carpet.
We ended up having to power wash
and extract this carpet four times.
After you spend 20
minutes on the same stain
or half an hour and keep working at it
and you can tell that
it's not changing color,
it's not coming out anymore,
and there's really not
that much more you can do,
you know as a detailer it's
kind of time to just call it.
I would say 85% of the stains
and the dirt were out of the carpet
and about 15% that was
just complete damage
was never going to come out.
We hung it up inside of a closet
where there's a heater.
So we actually had to
let it dry for two days.
So, dyeing the carpet
was actually a last-minute decision
that I ended up making myself.
The first step is to
spray dye on the carpet.
We use a brush to brush it into the carpet
to make sure it doesn't just sit,
'cause if it sits, then the carpet
will become, like, hard, bristly texture.
And then you'll go back
and you'll spray over it again.
And then you just let it sit and dry,
and that's really it.
The only things you
want to be careful about
are inhaling the fumes, so
we wore our respirators.
And because we're in a parking garage,
we have a really big exhaust
fan right next to us,
and we had that running the entire time.
And we don't do this on normal carpets,
or, honestly, ever,
but when we saw that some of the stains
weren't coming out, we wanted to make sure
that this is going to
really change someone's life
and they're going to be
happy when they receive it.
Embedded in the seats are grease.
And there was so much of it,
after we did the entire extraction
the first time, we let it dry overnight,
and we came back the next day,
and it was completely
covered in grease again.
So everything that was farther in the seat
came to the surface.
So we had to clean them a second time.
So, after we spray our extractor soap,
we'll let the soap sit
for about a minute or two,
and then we'll go ahead
and use the drill brush
to agitate the soap into the fibers,
and then we'll clean it
out with the extractor.
The extractor has a little nozzle
that sprays hot water into
the fibers of the seat.
And then it also has a vacuum head.
So as it's spraying the water into it,
it's sucking the water
out at the same time.
That way it can clean it.
We have a clear head on it,
so we can actually see all of the soap,
all of the dirt coming out of the seat.
And when that water coming
through is completely clear,
that's how you know
when the seat is clean.
So, now we're cleaning
the back seat of the car,
which was also one of the
grossest parts of the car.
And the first thing we
did was use the Tornador
to spray off any of the dirt.
And that is simply just
an air-compressor tool
that shoots out air in
a tornado formation.
And that'll get a lot of the dirt
out of the deeper fibers of the seat.
And then after that,
we'll go on to the extracting process.
The Tornador's best for getting
any kind of microparticles
out of the carpet or out of the seats
and then dust or dirt
or anything that's on the
topical layer as well.
So, at this point, we're
taking apart the center console
so we can get it out of the car
and pressure wash all
of the disgusting grease
and mold and everything off of it.
Dirt definitely gets behind both the radio
or any of the knobs on the center console,
because that's where your
hands are touching a lot.
So by dissembling those things
and cleaning behind them,
we know that we're sanitizing
and doing the best job
that we possibly can.
Sometimes the Tornador can't get things
that are super stuck on
if they're gooey or anything like that,
almost like a glue substance to plastics.
The air is not going to
do a good enough job,
so you have to scrape it
off and power wash it.
We wanted to give it a good
exterior cleaning, too.
It did have a thick layer
of dust on the exterior.
The engine bay was dirty.
The wheels had brake dust all over them.
Surprisingly enough,
dirt or dust actually acts
as a protectant to paint.
So when a car is dusty or
covered in a layer of dirt,
it protects it from the sun's UV rays.
So, the first thing that we do is
we spray our degreaser all over the paint,
'cause it's paint-safe,
and that'll just start
loosening up any of the
dirt on the outside.
And then we'll use our power washer
to get the dirt off.
So, after we wash the car,
we go ahead and we spray
the entire thing down
with the ceramic sealant
while it's still wet.
And that just gives it a
little bit of protection
and also a shine after we wash it.
And then we'll go ahead
and spray it down again
before drying it.
After we were done with it,
he actually needed to take
it back to his home shop
and do some mechanical work on it
to make sure it's safe for the people,
whoever owns it next.
We're really happy with
the result of this car,
but what meant the most to
us is how Parker reacted,
because this was something special to him.
And the fact that we
got to be a part of it
is why we did it in the first place.
We do all these details
absolutely for free.
So we took this on because
we wanted to make a change
and we wanted to help a
family that needed it.